uh who was your first ever celebrity
crush
the chemistry between zendaya and tom
holland and spider-man
is epic and so is it in real life the
peter parker and mj actors aren't the
only ones who began dating after playing
a couple on screen though
in fact they're not even the first
spider-man couple to do so
which actors spent seasons filming
together after breaking up
which hollywood couple ended their
relationship just a week before
their film premiered she's the most
down-to-earth regular easy-going girl
you'll ever meet
after years of denial quite possibly the
couple of gen z have officially
confirmed
they are an item we fell in love with
tom holland and zendaya
together when they played peter parker
and mj and now
that on-screen chemistry is happening a
whole lot more in real life
the two have been good friends for a
long time and have always been outwardly
supportive of each other
even when they were just pals i'm not
leaving my husband
sarah shaw he had actually recently
split from her husband steve howie when
she started filming sex life
on the set she met co-star adam demos
and was immediately taken
the two actors quickly discovered they
had loads in common
and shahi was eager to keep getting to
know her co-star their chemistry is
through the charts and it seems they've
fallen hard
since demos posted a photo on his
instagram wishing shahi a happy birthday
and calling her his
everything i love you gwen and i'll
follow you wherever you go
zenday and holland weren't the only
spider-man couple to fall in love
emma stone and andrew garfield met on
the set of the amazing spider-man
except instead of playing mj stone was
playing gwen stacy
stone and garfield were dating other
people but after both actors went
through breakups with their former
partners the pair found themselves
spending a lot of time together again
and officially began dating while they
were together they made countless red
carpet appearances and even were on snl
together
they dated for about four years before
calling it quits
evidently their breakup was a good one
since the two are still friends and
definitely care for each other
is that everything
i guess so they've been together more
than five years now so it seems the
stranger things couple is going strong
the two met playing a couple on the show
and reportedly started dating a bit
before season 2 had begun filming
the actors denied it for a while but
there were plenty of signs online that
they were together
like when they had matching wizard of oz
themed outfits for halloween in 2016.
december 2017 they made their red carpet
debut together a pretty official mark
for actors dating
natalia dyer has said that working with
heaton is a real treat and it allows
them a lot of freedom to play on set
i understand that do you
i do the two actors met on the set of
the king and discovered they had
loads in common with each other and
rumors they were dating started pretty
quickly
the romance was revealed by some
paparazzi photos even though they tried
to keep the relationship on the down low
the couple broke up in for business
reasons but they were seen together
again in 2021
sparking rumors that they could be
seeing each other again but
it seems as though they're just good
friends for now
he's a he's a hopeless romantic for sure
from reggie and veronica to camilla and
charles
this couple has made it through and the
actors are actually back together again
after a long breakup period
the two got together while filming
riverdale dated for about a year but
then broke up for nearly two
only in 2021 did they confirm they were
back together again
i won't let that happen lily collins and
taylor lautner met on the set of the
movie abduction
where they got pretty cozy sharing some
kisses according to fellow actor denzel
whitaker the two had
loads of sparks flying between them from
the day they met
collins described their steamy onset
kisses as totally comfortable
since lautner was so fun and made
everyone around him feel good
the relationship between these two
seemed to be going well enough but then
it was revealed that lautner broke up
with collins just
a week before the film premiere pretty
much the most awkward timing there is
romeo and juliet but we live happily
ever after instead
the chemistry between lily reinhart and
cole sprouse and riverdale was
definitely pretty real since the two
were sharing the same chemistry
off-camera the actors dated for nearly
three years but
eventually broke up in 2020. breakups
are always hard
especially after having spent so much
time with the other person
but the two actors have shown their
support for each other online
we can wink at each other and have a
camaraderie that's uh
you know stronger than a stronger over
the course of three movies you know the
upside down
kiss is pretty much one of the best
shots from the very first live-action
spider-man movie
with an image like that it's no surprise
the two actors started dating in secret
while filming as peter parker and mj
they only dated for a year but kept
things professional as they went on to
do two more films together in the same
roles
since they'd broken up before even
filming the second movie the director
sam raimi said he'd been worried it
would be awkward and that the two would
lose their chemistry
so maybe if you could just stop by the
booth for a little
i don't know i just it would mean a lot
to me
the two actors shared the screen in the
kissing booth and through working
together
ended up developing a real-life
friendship that naturally progressed
into a romantic one
after only about a year they decided to
call it quits
fortunately for the two most of the
sequel focused on them being in a long
distance relationship
so it's not like they had to fully play
out a romance together
every single day again this definitely
made it a bit easier to work together on
that sequel
we were friends and now we're more than
friends the big bang theory couple dated
very early on in their run of the series
together cuoco was interested in galecki
right away but he had a girlfriend at
the time
they started dating soon enough and kept
it really quiet but
eventually rumors did get spread and the
news became pretty public
they actually wound up filming pretty
much 10 full seasons after having broken
up
which is definitely awkward especially
when it came to very romantic or
physical scenes
the pair actually grew to be even closer
than before and have continued to
maintain a great relationship
the only other time i ever feel that way
is when i'm with you
they played lovers freddie mercury and
one-time fiance mary austin in bohemian
rhapsody and were quickly rumored to be
dating
the rumors were true and the couple has
been together since then and are still
going strong
malik gave boynton quite the shout out
when he called her the heart of the film
while giving an acceptance speech for
his role as mercury
you're the heart of this film you are
beyond immensely talented
both actors had been with co-stars they
met in romantic roles before
but when they played love interests in
the green lantern film
neither one had any idea what was coming
reynolds was still married at the time
and lively was busy dating gossip girl
co-star pimpagelate
so nothing happened while they were
together but their on-screen chemistry
was definitely there
a while later both relationships ended
and the actors got together officially
in 2011 and have been together ever
since
the couple even has three kids together
and pretty much remain one of the most
adorable celebrity couples there is
my dress is made of the purest silk from
tralalalala aliday
rose leslie and kit harrington played
lovers on game of thrones
and very quickly after there were rumors
they started an off-screen relationship
as well
they became friends really quickly and
the relationship just grew from there
they did end up breaking up actually
around the same time their characters
broke up
but after a while and after leslie's
character had passed away on game of
thrones
the two got back together in 2014. this
was followed by yet
another breakup a year later and then in
2016
they finally went fully public with
their relationship on the red carpet and
have been together ever since
i like watching you sleep it's um
it's kind of fascinating to me these two
were
the it couple in hollywood for a while
fans
couldn't get enough of their on-screen
chemistry in twilight
stewart said that she was very much in
love with pattinson but
in the end their relationship called
quits after nearly four years
we don't know anything and that is the
only thing you can feel like you know is
that if you're in love with someone
watching so many of these on-screen
couples and knowing they dated in real
life
makes the experience that much better
it's hard to tell what is performance
and what's real sometimes
which is your favorite real-life couple
born from an on-screen romance